although they do also time some happy
sharing all these vlogs they got me
watching brothers Mitchell Davis Manilow
and graphics oh no it's not
so that song was inspired by the
subscribe-button pillow my friend
Roberto makes these he sent me one and
as soon as I took it out of the package
I started singing my subs my subs my
subs my stuff and I wanted to make him a
little video and show you guys how
awesome this is he has a ton of internet
themed pillows little iChat icons and
all kinds of other awesome things so
check him out through Wacom and you guys
him by pillow either this one or any
other one that's awesome you guys were
wondering why didn't fit more youtubers
into that song because I could only fit
certain people's names in a certain
spots and every one that I put in there
their names happen to fit just perfectly
into the song so yeah thank you guys for
watching and um leave me a comment
saying whatever you want okay bye